>> Ed: IS JOINING US NOW AS
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE MARK ESPER
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU
COMING IN.
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS HAS A MAJOR
STORY THIS MORNING BREAKING
SAYING THAT THERE WERE SIX KEY
DAYS WHEN THIS OUTBREAK STARTED
TO WEAR A TOP CHINESE OFFICIALS
KEPT IT QUIET.
THEY KNEW THAT THIS WAS ALL
DEVELOPING.
THEY ESSENTIALLY COVERED IT UP
AND THEY LET MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
TRAVEL AROUND THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
AND HERE WE ARE NOW THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS WHO HAVE DIED.
OUR ENTIRE ECONOMY UPENDED WHAT
CAN YOU DO IN THE DAYS AHEAD TO
HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE?
>> FIRST LET ME SPEAK TO WHAT
DOD IS DOING.
THE UNITED STATES.
FROM THE BEGINNING GOING BACK TO
LATE JANUARY THE DOD HAS BEEN
ALL IN WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND BEEN CONSISTENTLY AHEAD OF
THE CURVE WHEN WE HAVE DEPLOYED
EQUIPMENT, AND TROOPS AND
DOCTORS AND NURSES TO AMERICAN
CITIES.
WE’VE BEEN ALL IN AND WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT, I’M PROUD
OF THE SERVICE MEMBERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND ABROAD WHO ARE
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO OUR GREAT
COUNTRY.
WITH REGARD TO CHINA AND THE
INFORMATION COMING OUT OF THERE,
AS MANY OF US HAVE SPOKEN FROM
FOLKS ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM, CLEARLY THE CHINESE
COULD HAVE BEEN MORE TRANSPARENT
EARLIER AND SHARED MUCH MORE OF
THE DATA.
WE WOULD HAVE HAD A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS VIRUS AND
HOW TO DEAL WITH IT AND EVEN
TODAY WE SEE THEM WITHHOLDING
INFORMATION.
I THINK WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
CONTINUE TO PRESSURE THE
SHERIFF.
THE TOUR OF RESOLUTION TO GET
BACK TO NEAR NORMAL IS THAT WE
ALL COOPERATE, AND, HE’S BEEN
SAYING WE DON’T KNOW WHERE FOR
SURE THIS STARTED.
WHEN WILL WE BE ABLE TO
CONCLUSIVELY DETERMINE WHERE WE
ARE IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
I WON’T SPEAK TO INTELLIGENCE
REPORTING BEYOND THAT, BUT I
THINK MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE IT
BEGAN NATURALLY.
IT WAS ORGANIC, IF YOU WILL.
IN DUE COURSE ONCE WE GET
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC THERE WILL
BE TIME TO LOOK BACK AND